you think being in Kansas how to help it
to find you having the career that you
have now starting off young really
taught me the importance of community
and actually some some stuff come up
with my mom of diagnosed with cancer
when I was younger and through that
whole experience it really just showed
me like what Wichita was had our backs
our families back providing food every
night for us and stuff like that because
Mom she was everything in the house wow
all that but you know once she was
cancer-free it just kind of like opened
my eyes once I got a little older to
like whatever platform I I use I'm going
to use it um back to communities I have
some special Mama Warrior too